You'll see that in every systems research paper, there is heavy lifting to be
done to take a concept to implementation.
Working out the details and ensuring that
all the corner cases are covered is
a non-trivial intellectual exercise in building distributed
subsystems. Like this one, the global memory
system. What is enduring in a research
exercise like this one? The concept of
paging across the network is an interesting
thought experiment, but it may not be
feasible exactly for the environment in which the
authors carried out this research, namely workstation
clusters connected by a local area network. Each
workstation in that setting is a private
resource owned by an individual who may or
may not want to share his resources,
memory in particular. On the other hand, data
centers today are powered by large scale
clusters on the order of thousands of processes
connected by a local area network. No
node is individually owned in that setting. Could
this idea of paging across the local
area network be feasible in that setting? Perhaps.
Even beyond the thought experiment itself what is perhaps more enduring
are the techniques, distributed data structures
and the algorithms, for taking the
concept of implementation. In the next part of this lesson module,
we will see another thought experiment to put cluster memory to use.